c'est une toute petite rue de saint
philippe où ne vivent que six familles
la rue jean albany a été rebaptisé il ya
quelques années seulement
mais elle ne porte pas encore de plaques
du coup elle pourrait passer inaperçu
tout comme l'oeuvre de jean albany est
ce que vous savez qui était jean albany
non pas du tout c'était un esclave qui a
découvert la fécondation de la vanille à
la bannière ses premiers habitants de
safi ni peut-être non
il paraît qu était un poète c'était
quelqu'un de bien mais bon j'ai entendu
dire que c'était un poète mais qu'est ce
qu'elle poèmes fils de marie antoinette
et ludovic albanie tous deux
instituteurs jean né en 1917 à saint
denis
à 20 ans il part à paris pour suivre des
études de droit et de chirurgie dentaire
deux ans plus tard il est mobilisé et
sert comme officier d'artillerie à
fontainebleau
c'est pendant la débâcle française qu'il
écrit ses premiers poèmes un teigneux
lafleur étrange du cadeau
en 1941 il commence à apprendre la
peinture à l'académie julian il n'en
délaisse pas ses précédentes études pour
autant et décroche une licence de droit
un doctorat en économie politique et son
diplôme de chirurgien dentiste
un métier qu'il pratiquera pendant 30
ans dans la rue lepic à paris entre 1945
et 48 il séjourne à la réunion et
constitue son glossaire de mots créoles
pendant cette période il expose au musée
léon dierx qui a qui est une de ces
heurts de retour à paris il publie son
premier recueil à mal en 1964 il
décroche le prix des mascareignes de
l'association des écrivains de langue
française pour miel vert mais jean
albany aime aussi écrire en créole son
premier livre en créole bleus mascarin
sort en 1969
c'est au total une douzaine d'oeuvres
que publiera le dentiste réunionnais
dans le dos aux hommes dans la sq à caen
l'asca bouvier tôt à sa mort en 1984 il
est enterré à la saline